alors il ya un peu plus d'un an la coop
21 et est à paris et on ya parlé de
somme oui des sols papa le sol sur
lesquels je marche un pas le plancher
par le macadam ou non les sols les
piquets en vivant de la planète
on a parlé de sol parce qu'on s'est
aperçu qu'il pouvait apporter des
solutions
salut du changement climatique alors
qu'à ce titre et que moi je parle de sol
prenant mes études j'étais très attiré à
la fois par deux choses à la fois par
les mots le minéral et qui par le vivant
ce qui m'a mis assez naturellement me
spécialiser en pédologie étude des sols
parce que les sols c'est ça hein la
rencontre entre la roche le vivant la
rencontre entre liban des racines haut
niveau autour la rencontre double vivent
les bactéries ou minéraux tout pour leur
niche
j'ai fait une thèse sur les associations
organo mis les ralentisseurs je suis
devenu chercheur à l'inra en 20 ans puis
professeur à agroparistech donc dans
cette maison est un milieu de travail et
je suis spécialisé sur les matières
organiques des sols et leur interaction
avec les minières ont convoyé toujours
un peu la même curiosité
ce qui m'amène à vous parler de sol ce
soir c'est quand j'ai envie de vous
inviter à penser seul parce que les sols
sont importants parce qu'ils sont en
danger parce qu'on peut faire quelque
chose
et parce qu'ils importunaient des
solutions alors les soldes sont
importants parce que c'est grâce à eux
que vous poussent les plantes et qu'elle
nous apporte matériaux combustibles
fibres et alimentation que beaucoup
cette photo parce qu'on voit la fois la
cime de blanc de pommes de terre qui est
le paysage est loin les alpes l'iphone
on estime que 90
pour cent de notre alimentation bien
directement ou indirectement des sommes
95% pour et sur les sols tombe
les précipitations c'est là qu'elle
s'infiltre elles vont alimenter les
nappes au passage leur composition peut
être chaud donc les sein de la sphère de
la quantité et la qualité de la
ressource en eau et puis c'est aussi sur
des sols qui arrivent tous les déchets
de nos écosystèmes les écosystèmes
terrestres sont par exemple les feuilles
les bois morts en forêt mais aussi les
déchets nos activités activités
domestiques activités agricoles fumiers
lisiers composts et dans les sols des
organismes des sols décompose toute
cette matière qui arrive cette matière
va regagner qui arrive et on libère
progressivement les éléments carbone
azote phosphore souffre et c'est qui ce
bon d'être disponible pour être utilisé
par les plantes grand recyclage et ceux
qui font ces transformations de là ce
sont les êtres vivants du sol et les
êtres vivants du sol il va ya une
infinie variété de formes de tailles de
couleurs de fonction en préparant cette
aile positif pour cette aide
j'ai pensé à les choses les saintes
c'est ma roue quand on fait de la
peinture
vous avez peut-être remarqué on mélange
de couleurs ensemble ça fait du bien en
général on ne peut pas très content
d'ailleurs c'est assez moche et va les
soldes quand on les regarde de loin ce
moment il semble un roman mais quand on
les regarde de près c'est d'un
psychologue
alors les sols on n'y pense pas mais ils
s'assurent de nombreuses fonctions et ne
dépendant d'eux vraiment dans notre vie
quotidienne
le problème c'est qu'ils sont en danger
sont menacées et il a de multiples que
manas
sûrement sauvé deux l'érosion parce que
c'est la plus importante à l'échelle
mondiale la terreur
et puis l'urbanisation et
l'artificialisation parce que c'est
celle qui s'aggrave le s'aggrave le plus
par exemple non seulement se pique ça
c'est une photo du plateau de saclay et
vous avez un lotissement qui tenteraient
grignoter sur debian zarab ces soirs là
ça fait partie des plus actives du monde
on estime que en france 27 mètres carrés
sont artificialisés par seconde c'est à
dire de vienne par qui des changeurs
bretelle d'autoroute et les abords et
ses 27 m² par la surface de 7 ans fille
je pense que toutes les cinq secondes la
surface de 7 ans fille est artificialisé
en france un assez impressionnant donc
des menaces est ce qu'on peut faire
quelque chose mais on peut faire quelque
chose
on peut par exemple couvrir les sols
pour les protéger contre l'émotion avec
une culture intermédiaire avec de
l'enherbement au vignoble avec on peut
limiter l'érosion aussi avec des avec
des arbres ont deux restaurer la
biodiversité des sols par les pratiques
agricoles raté de crédit ni sous la
bourre et ça restera un certain nombre
d'organismes du sol
des pratiques qui relèvent de
l'agriculture biologique qui a
différentes les différentes voies on
peut aussi karine légation raisonner
avec une qualité de façon limitée à 7
on peut dépolluer les sols même avec des
web de logique pour les décontaminer
donc il ya des palettes de solution est
en fait ce dont je voudrais vous parler
surtout ce soir c'est des solutions que
les soldats portent eux à d'autres
problèmes
j'ai choisi une photo d'un rebond
pourrait durer plaindra d'exemple
plainte de situation j'en ai choisi 3 la
première c'est ça octobre 2015
cagnes-sur-mer les inondations pour un
pétard qu'elles ont été meurtrières on a
vu les gens ont entendu à la radio à la
télé que le changement climatique
on était partiellement responsable dont
le nom dans cette région méditerranéenne
il y à des précipitations violentes
extrêmement intense périodiquement on
appelle ça les épisodes cévenols et puis
et puis dans la région de kayes
actionnaires dans la région de miss long
la preuve doit s'infiltrer
parce que tout est construit tout et
tout est bétonnée parce que la ville
s'est détendu et du kulo magris à la
surface du lac la table elle court elle
dévale avec les conséquences que l'on
sait et donc là si on veut limiter le
risque d'inondation seront pas que ça se
reproduise l'année prochaine en espérant
comme ça se reproduit quelques dizaines
d'années on a tout intérêt à s'appuyer
sur les sols pour qu'ils puissent
infiltrer les eaux de cris mais ça c'est
pas évident à sa pose pas mal de
problèmes ça veut dire i need l
urbanisation à limiter cette
consommation particulièrement de terres
agricoles limiter l'urbanisation limiter
l'imperméabilisation du couple danse à
leur milieu en même temps il faudrait
que l'on puisse impliquerait le site
dans les villes
donc comment préserver des sols en ville
tout en ne gagnant pas trop sur les
terres autour des villes qui comment
avoir de la nature en ville parce que
quand même n'a pas forcément
dans une ville complètement les données
donc ça remis en question sa pose
vraiment des questions de femmes
d'urbanisation et ça oblige à réfléchir
à la ville que nous voulons demain c'est
un vrai défi
mais les soldes donc pourrait peuvent
écrans télé précipitation et l'aider à
se protéger des inondations
deuxième question dont je vous parlais
de l'agriculture
les sols sont un partenaire
indispensable si on veut si nous voulons
rigolo bellamine agriculture qui soit
plus économe en intrants plus économe en
intrants qu'est ce que je veux dire
c'est plus économes en énergie plus
économes en eau plus économe en
fertilisants de synthèse ou partisans
qui proviennent de mines plus agréments
aux pesticides de synthèse et ça ça
demande de s'appuyer sur les sols par
exemple les plans de jean d'éléments
minéraux se nourrir
je vous ai parlé de ce recyclage quel
lieu dans l'ensemble qui vers des
éliminés mot différentes manières de
faire couvrir le sol croissance de la
végétation qui est la matière qui 40
gagne et qui rentre dans les sols
utilisés des légumineuses dans les
rotations comme ici ça c'est ça c'est en
france et puis ça c'est à madagascar
parce qu'elle fixe la zone de l'air
elles enrichissent le sol en azote est
cuit à perte et un certain nombre de nos
déchets organiques ses latéraux qu'elle
commence à se montrer sur les sols y
compris les déchets des ide
ça ce sont des déchets ce sont des
composts de déchets verts de la
communauté de communes de versailles
par exemple à la mer morte émission il
faut si on veut le sol puisse fournir
des éléments minéraux
il faut bull dans la porte donc il faut
lui apporter de la biomasse il faut y
apporter de la matière organique nous
peut s'appuyer sur les soldats derrière
la plainte pratique impliqué il ya même
0 diable pratique qui a cours de forme
d'agriculture dont vous entendez les
noms qui qui vous intéressent pas
peut-être vous
l'égalité peut-être lyon agriculture
biologique agroécologie agroforesterie
permaculture agriculture de conservation
selon les contextes selon ses
convictions ses priorités ont choisi
l'un monte mais toutes ces agricultures
ou en commun de s'appuyer sur les sols
et d'avoir absolument besoin des sols
donc là aussi les sols apporte des
solutions
et puis troisième exemple l'image de
venir là comme maintenir à la com 21
donc si on s'est intéressé au sol a
lancé voilà l'enjeu à l'enjeu de la
lutte contre les changements climatiques
cette arrivée à diminuer la
concentration en co2 dans l'atmosphère
au-dessus des sols les plantes elles
croissent en fixant entourant le carbone
de l'atmosphère
c'est le 2 dioxyde de carbone leur
matière et fait à peu près qu'on retient
de carbone
quand elles vendent leurs matières
retombe sur les sols est incorporé au
sol et là je l'écris elle est décomposé
par les organismes vivants du sol c'est
ce recyclage et in fine et donc ça se
passe là in fine et du carbone libéré à
nouveau sous forme de cm2 est rejeté
dans l'atmosphère
le cycle du carbone passe par me sol il
passe et passe très vite
en moyenne les matières organiques elle
reste dans un sol voilà entre l'entrée
et la sortie elle s'est excusée en
dizaines d'années ce qui fait qu'il ya
un réservoir l'a carrément un gros
réservoir et scénarise à voir qu'il fait
le ménage à l'échelle de la planète et
du coup de toutes petites variations de
ce réservoir pourrait avoir des
conséquences sur l'effet de serre par
exemple de toute petite diminution de
ceux les avoir on entre au moins de
carbone qui ont ensemble pour elles par
exemple déforestation mauvaise gestion
des sols pourraient aggraver
sérieusement les lecteurs de tout
l'augmentation est donc une estimation
faite par des scientifiques une
augmentation de 0 4 pour mille exemples
moins de 1% de 15 du carbone qui est
située dans les soldes en la matière
organique du sol
pompey de l'atmosphère via la végétation
pour est une toute petite augmentation
comme ça pourrait compenser pour être
pompée autant que ce que nous héritons
annuellement sous forme de carbone
fossile alors une chose assez il est pas
question surtout il n'est pas question
de demander au sol de faire notre
travail c'est à dire que nous devons
changer le mode de vie peut pas demander
aux soldes libres à notre place par
contre ça mérite sacrément d'être
analysée et c'est ce qui a expliqué car
c est à l'origine une initiative qui a
été lancé à la fin terex a permis natif
4 combines qui a pour objectif
d'augmenter ce réservoir de carbone
d'augmenter la teneur en carbone la
teneur en matière organique des sols
alors comment est-ce qu'on peut le faire
par exemple par une fontaine plus
devaient reproduire plus légers talent
et l'incorporer au sol par exemple
l'agroforesterie tuera le terrain
très vite temporaire bandes enherbées
cultures associées
il faut restituer les résidus de culture
ce sont des pratiques dont je vous ai
déjà parlé à votre lutte contre
l'érosion à propos des évolutions de
l'agriculture donc en fait les pratiques
qui permettent d'augmenter le carbone
des sols monter la matière organique des
sols
elles ont de multiples bénéfices et rien
que ça c'est une raison pour y arriver
alors ni raison pour y aller est ce que
c'est facile non ça paraît si c'est pas
possible partout d'augmenter ce stockage
du carbone cette quantité de matière
organique dans les sols parce qu'il peut
y avoir des 1000 climatiques assez d'eau
par exemple les limites agronomique des
systèmes de cultures qui sont inadaptés
à la région à l'endroit où contexte
économique des limites sociologique des
limites économiques mais c'est pas une
raison pour tag aller et ça pose plein
de questions de connaissances
ça pose plein de questions de
connaissances et par exemple dans mon
équipe nous nous intéressons david eng
hen je suis nous nous intéressons vase
mais si on comprend pourquoi est ce que
les matières organiques est presque
aussi vous tente dans les sols
alors que la plupart d'entre elles sont
parfaitement consommable par des
micro-organismes une des explications
c'est que dans cet essai de la crainte
très complexe qu'est le sol les
microorganismes n'arrive pas à les
rencontrer n'arrive pas à trouver leur
nourriture
alors j'ai choisi pour illustrer sa
scène ses photos c'est une photo prise
il ya un microscope et tonita un très
fort retentissement ce que vous avez
c'est un petit peu de matière organique
ou le rayon vert et quelques colonies de
bactéries aux tourelles elles ont trouvé
la source de nourriture elles sont
entrés en contact à la une the elles se
reproduisent là ils sont en train de
composer mais apparemment c'est qu'ils
sont d'accessibilité sont tout à fait
d'une tente alors ce qui est très ou
assez trop bien dans cette cette
initiative a finalement cette fois ça
fait ça fait trente ans que je travaille
sur
des sols et tout d'un coup je suis
rejointe et ma communauté scientifique
proche nous sommes rejoints nous sommes
interpellés par l'actualité politico
gouvernementale alors c'est très
excitant c'est très stimulant parce que
ça me faisait preuve d'économie de droit
de l'agronomie et c'est donc ça nous
incite à les ouvrir à échanger avec les
collègues d'autres disciplines
et puis aussi parce que c'est le mieux
qui dure c'est clair nous demande et
combien et ô combien de temps ils vont
faire et combien ça va coûter
donc on est vraiment mais au pied du
nord en tant que chercheur il faut dire
qu'en tant que chercheur d'un large
public la manche lassée
ça fait un peu peur mais voilà c'est
c'est très excitant
voilà donc utilisé les soldes pour
lutter contre le changement climatique
limiter le changement climatique
oui cette ville des voix il ya des
multiples encore il ya des multiples
manières de le faire bien impuni est ce
que je voudrais vous dire c'est que y'a
pas que les sols n'y a pas que les sols
mais les sols apporte des solutions
et puis quand on parle de sol en fait ça
ne revienne pas dans une boîte
ça a même à parler d'autres questions
settoul et alimentaire sécurité
énergétique santé sécurité des
ressources en eau parce que les soldes
sont liés à tous ces enjeux et c'est une
des choses que j'ai particulièrement
marqués danger n'était donc dans cette
mission d'ambassadrice des sols très
grave de la leaf à oger dernier discuter
avec des personnes extrêmement variés et
ce que j'ai trouvé particulièrement
fertile c'est qu'on commence à parler
sol devant festivités fertilité donc à
l'agriculture voulons nous allons
qu'éducation à mes accès à la terre
avant le droit à la propriété arriver
les militants tamouls
alors est ce que les conflits liés à
l'eau est une organisation qui peut même
qu'ils consomment consomment du sol
quelles qu'elles vivent voulons nous
donc en fait ça ne referme pas mais ça
voudra plein de questions autres plein
de questions environnementales et
savoura penser en termes de solutions je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]